so
i'd like to just go through a little bit
of the tai chi
exercises not the
not the form so this i'm only be talking
about exercises so that you can do them
daily take your feet apart
if you know that your balance isn't good
or if you find after doing
trying the first few moves you know if
you
go up on your toes and you find you're
wobbling about
just take hold of a some object that's a
get a chair or something and help
yourself
the aim is to achieve
not to destroy
the purpose of tai chi is
to find yourself find who you are be
gentle with yourself
and in turn be gentle with the
the outside world
so
just calm in my breath
i'm going slowly into finding a state of
[Music]
calmness
you don't have to wait for your breath
to become
but it's nice because you're you're
relaxing you're
sort of settling
we'll start with the toes because
these we need to make the legs strong
make them very strong like all the
muscles the tendons the ligaments
everything strung all the way up all the
way up to your hips
all the way up to your pelvis around the
back
then stimulate the kidneys
through the digestion system
slightly working all the way through the
body
so that your body is more efficient it's
running more smoother
your blood is circulating better
and the chinese do this because they say
that
they're bringing health to their self
their bodies
first we must have very strong powerful
legs
because if you have powerful legs my
mr frame my master would say strong legs
means that the spine can sit
firmly on them knowing that the legs
will hold the spine
if the spine knows that it has a
powerful base to sit on
and uphold itself then the spine will
become strong
and with a strong spine
it becomes a healthy spine so i'm going
to just
start to come up with my toes
check you find your balance
if you want to do this with your breath
you can
but for now just check your breathing
it doesn't want to be struggling
try to stay calm i'll just slowly go
down
don't go down in the hurry for these
exercises
i'll show you from the rear
so i'm going to go a bit hip width apart
not really
much about my feet they're just going to
be in the natural
position and then as i
think of breathing in i raise
i carry on breathing naturally
if you need something to hold on perhaps
get a chair
close by before you start to say you're
having to
disturb yourself
this will and then slowly down
this will work on all the calf muscles
making them really strong you kill these
tendons
a little wider apart your in-breath
come up this way you'll be
working your feet feeling outwards
and you can check them
just working a little bit on that
thighs the calves are working
so a little wide i'm just showing you
from both sides
as i breathe in i come up
slowly down show you from the side
you don't want to stick your butt out
your belly forward
try to be over yourself
over the hole of yourself nice and loose
okay i breathe in through the nose a lot
in and out through the nose
some people breathing out to the mouth
better to filter it through the nose you
have more control
so so
when you're when you're in that stage
try
to concentrate on your breath
and and and a blank mind try to
enjoy the pose
there's another pose where you can
stand a little bit more bent leg
a little bit more bent leg so now
it's like sitting okay this is if i'm
sitting here
bentley this is going to strengthen the
knees
the thighs
you can either stay in this position
don't tip the head back just keep it
still
and with an in-breath if you want to try
this
don't try everything
we're too impatient because the humor
makes we always want to do
more than what we should enjoy each
piece
do each piece if you can build up to
10 minutes in each pose you're doing
more than really well okay
and there's another pose
the arms are soft it's as if they're
being held up
with pegs by the fingers
do everything slowly
check the head
working on the thighs working on the
knees
slowly anyone with bad knees
you'll still have bad knees if they're
worn but the ligaments and tendons
around the knees will become
strong and support those weak knee
joints
if you want to take it further
breathe in
relax the elbows
you want to feel as if the chest is open
and stays open
you don't want to close it in
arms come down push into the legs
to the feet close
i built i build up in my uh
own training i build up to holding
the poses for up to 20 minutes
but this is not a uh a challenge for you
to do it
this long i'm just explaining
what you can build up to it's very
demanding on the legs
you might need to shake your legs out a
little
at the end of it shake your arms out a
just try to
lose enough
try and be loose
nice circles
you can place one hand here the other
hand on your back
in time you'll be able to send your
energy
through this place in your hand
your own g you're about to send it
through your own body
and feel it on your back and
by pushing it through your own body your
mind is directing your chi
into yourself and in the end you should
feel it
on this back hand getting warmer
and increasing of power
okay it's um about five to seven
centimeters below your navel this point
that you connect with
and you connect it with the palm of your
hand
when we finish we cover the fist
rebound some say
we have the power of the five oceans
and we're covering so that
the opponents cannot see our power
others say it's the five continents of
the world
with all its power behind it
and i don't want to show it because i
need to keep this power
but this is the stance that you'll see
and this uh the bowel you sometimes see
thank you for your time and
we'll just keep going through the
exercises
please try and do them
and hold them as long as you can set
yourself some goals
set yourself some timing goals you know
if you wear a watch just say okay
i would try and do this for five minutes
of course five minutes is far you know a
long long time if you've never done it
before
so give yourself a minute and then
if you want to do it another day the
more regu the more you put in
the more you will get out the stronger
the body
the body memory will remember it so if
you come back to it in three four days
time
the body will soon remember what you've
done
you know if you don't overwatch have a
clock or
you know don't set your alarm on the
phone because
this is another pressure we don't want
pressures
just just set yourself some goals but
sensible achievable goals
if you're standing up here and you're
shaking like a leaf
and you want to get that extra
and you're struggling
it's it's okay if that if that's what
you're really wanting to do
persecute yourself but you should be
enjoying
tai chi is all about
experiencing
the moment experience the wind
going through these gaps in the fingers
experience the air as you pass through
it
the air is in this room
so enjoy enjoy it
thank you for watching